we're asked to multiply and to simplify
and we have x squared minus the
principal square root of 6 times x
squared plus the principal square root
of 2 and so we really just have two
binomials two two-term expressions that
we want to multiply and there's multiple
ways to do this
I'll show you kind of the more intuitive
way and then I'll show you the way it's
taught in some algebra classes which
might be a little bit faster but
requires a little bit of memorization so
I'll show you the intuitive way first so
if you have anything so if I have let's
say I have a times X plus y we know from
the distributive property that this that
this is the same thing as a X plus a Y
and so we can do the same thing over
here if you view a as x squared as this
whole expression over here x squared
minus the principal square root of 6 and
you view X plus y is this thing over
here
you can distribute you we can distribute
all of this we can distribute all of
this on to let me do it this way
distribute this entire term onto this
term and onto that term so let's do that
so we get x squared minus the principle
square root of 6 times this term I'll do
it in yellow times x squared and then we
have Plus this thing again we're just
distributing it it's just like this a
it's sometimes not that intuitive
because this is a big expression but you
can treat it just like you would treat a
variable over here you're distributing
it over this expression over here and so
then we have x squared minus the
principle square root of 6 times the
principle square root of 2 times the
principle square root of 2 and now we
can do the distribute the distributive
property again but what we'll do is
we'll distribute each of these we'll
distribute this x squared onto each of
these terms and distribute the square
root of 2 onto each of these terms it's
the exact same thing as here it's just
you could imagine writing it like this X
plus y times a is still going to be a X
plus a Y and just to see the pattern how
this is really the same thing as this up
here we're just switching the order of
the multiplication you can kind of view
it as redistribute
from the right and so if you do this you
get x squared times x squared which is X
to the fourth
that's that times that and then minus x
squared times the principal square root
of six minus x squared times the
principal square root of six and then
over here you have square root of two
times x squared so plus x squared times
the square root of two and then you have
square root of two times the square root
of six and we have a negative sign out
here now if you take the square root of
two let me do this on the side square
root of two times the square root of six
we know from simplifying radicals so
this is the exact same thing as the
square root of two times six or the
square root or the principal square root
of 12 so the square root of 2 times
square root of 6 we have a negative sign
out here it becomes minus the square
root of 12 and let's see if we can
simplify this at all well see you have
an X to the fourth term right and then
here you have well depending on how you
want to view it you could say look we
have two second degree terms we have
something times x squared and we have
something else times x squared so if you
want you could simplify these two terms
over here so I have two square root of
two x Squared's and then I have square
root of 6 and then I'm going to subtract
from that square root of 6 X Squared's
so you could view this as square root of
2 minus square root of 6 or the
principal square root of 2 minus the
principal square root of 6 x squared and
then if you want square root of 12 you
might be able to simplify that 12 is the
same thing as 3 times 4 so square root
of 12 is equal to square root of 3 times
square root of 4 and the square root of
4 or the principal square root of 4 I
should say is 2 so square root of 12 is
the same thing as 2 square roots of 3 so
instead of writing the principal square
root of 12 we could write minus 2 times
the principal square root of 3 and then
out here you have an X to the 4th you
have an X to the fourth plus this and
you see if you distributed this out if
you distribute this x squared you would
get this term negative x squared square
root of 6 and if you distribute it onto
this you'd get that term so you could
debate which of these two is
more is more simple now I mentioned that
this way I just did the distributive
property twice nothing new nothing fancy
but in some classes you will see
something called foil and we I think
we've done this in previous videos foil
now I'm not a big fan of it because it's
really a way to memorize a process as
opposed to understanding that this is
really just from the common sense
distributive property but all this is is
a way to make sure that you're
multiplying everything times everything
when you're doing a when you're
multiplying two binomials times each
other like this and foil just says look
first multiply the things on the first
multiply the first term so x squared
times x squared is X to the fourth then
multiply the outside so then multiply
under this in green then multiply the
outside so the outside terms are x
squared and square root of two and so x
squared times square root of two and
they're positive is so plus square root
of two times x squared and then multiply
the inside and you can see why I don't
like it that much is because you really
don't know what you're doing you're just
applying an algorithm then you multiply
the inside and so negative square root
of six times x squared so negative
square root of six times x squared and
then you multiply the last term's and
then you multiply the last term so
negative square root of six times square
root of two that is and we already know
that that is negative square root of 12
negative square root of 12 which you can
also then simplify to that expression
right over there so it's fine to use
this it's although it's good even if you
do use this to know where foil comes
from it really just comes from the using
the distributive property twice